Brandi was 8 years old when her father was
taken from her and her story is not unique,
she's just one of the hundred thousand American
children each year
who lose at least one parent to deportation.
And now she's just one of the many children
Nora Sandigo provides for.
I'm the legal guardian for 817 kids.
Yes, you heard her correctly, Nora Sandigo,
a Miami resident,
is providing for 817 US Citizen children who
have been effected by parental deportations.
Most of my kids suffer a lot because they
don't know that if,
at that point of their life they can be alone
because the father or mother was deported
or could be deported.
Family unity is a non partisan value,
however, mixed status families bring a unique
twist when dealing with immigration policy.
Should immigrants who have established American
families
be forgiven for their illegal entry into the
country?
President Obama says yes and has attempted
to address these issues through executive action.
However real and lasting change must come
through Congress
and until that happens many American children
remain uncertain of their family's future.
The two major principles of immigration law
are protecting American workers
but the other part is family unification.
Ira Kurzban has been a Miami based immigration
lawyer for over 30 years.
And what the president is doing is focusing
on that second one and saying
'if you have an American citizen child or
a lawful permanent resident child
we're gonna let you stay here and take care
of your child.'
That's not something that's on the government,
you are illegally here,
you lied repeatedly and probably committed
a whole string of other crimes
identity theft and what have you, perjury,
tax fraud
and you're now going to have to pay for that
not by going to jail, but just by going back home
to your own country.
You can take your little kids with you.
But you have to bear the responsibility for
your crimes.
Mark Krikorian is the director of the Center
for Immigration Studies
a think tank that argues for less immigration
altogether.
There's nothing that prevents immigrants being
deported from taking their kids with them.
But immigration lawyers say that's not true.
When illegal immigrants are caught, they're
often detained far from where their families live
and are physically unable to take care of
their children.
Once the child protective services are involved
it can be very difficult for an illegal immigrant
to retain custody of their children.
The question is who takes care of the child?
If the child becomes a dependent on the state
then the state has to find a family that will
take care of the child
just like any other American citizen.
In 2011, at least 5100 children were int he
foster care system due to parental deportation.
This costs the government on average about
26000 dollars a year
for every child in foster care.
This means that in 2011,
the US spent at the very least 133 million
dollars on foster care for these children.
In more recent years, that figure may be over
600 million dollars
as the number of children is estimated to
be closer to 15000.
These parents have signed a contract before
their deportation
granting Nora powers of attorney over their
kids.
That way if the parents are deported,
Nora is there to make sure the children are
placed in good homes
with families or friends.
They're using this foster care argument as
a wedge
to argue that the parents should be able to stay
but that discussion is not even appropriate
as a political discussion
not because the parents of kids who were born
here shouldn't at some point get amnesty
I mean I don't like it, but you can't rewind
the video.
The problem, the core problem to me is that
we haven't actually created the conditions
the pre-conditions for that kind of amnesty.
We have such a large illegal immigrant population
because our political class
has simply refused to enforce the existing
laws.
One law many anti-immigration advocates would
consider not enforcing, however,
is the 14th Amendment.
End automatic citizenship at birth,
it's not just being abused by illegal immigrants,
it's being abused by tourists,
foreign students have kids here, graduate
students here for a few years
and then they leave and those kids aren't
American.
This conservative argument, known as the anchor
baby argument
rests on the idea that birthright citizenship
encourages people to come to the US illegally
and have children in hopes that their American
child will grant them benefits or legal status.
That ended in 1977, after 1977 you're child
has to be 21 years old to petition for you.
So the concept of somebody coming here and
having a child
so the child can petition for them is ridiculous,
there's no such thing as an anchor baby anymore.
Studies show that most illegal immigration
to the United States is driven by economic factors
not the attraction of birthright citizenship.
But for these mixed status families any economic
gain they might have achieved in the US
is stretched thin when deportation enters
the picture.
Statistically it's mostly the father that
gets deported
leaving single mothers struggling to make
ends meet.
Nora says she can't solve all the problems
her kids face.
It is beautiful but sometimes it's so difficult.
She has been a kind of a beacon for people
who know that she is the person here locally
who you can depend on and she's tried to do
as she can in the circumstances.
President Obama's executive stand on deportations
is still in effect.
But even if it survives court challenges brought
forth by Republicans
it will still expire in 2016 when Obama leaves
office.
In order to provide lasting relief to these
American children
Congress needs to enact a more humane and
comprehensive immigration policy.